I just want to start by saying that this
is what he does he tries to elevate
himself okay we all know ed Sheeran and
Taylor Swift are BFF ffs
I mean they've collaborated on music
reputation precedes me they go hiking
together you okay bro it's called
exercise have you ever done cardio
they've toured together they tease each
other like experts will study this and
say that you're like what are you doing
you're like peacocking right now honey
cuz you wear it all the time but know
what I did for you today I mean it has
even posted a picture of Taylor's cat
Meredith so you know it's serious but
with all this Taylor and Scooter Braun
drama
everyone's been like where is Ed Sheeran
seriously his Instagram comments we're
getting spammed by Swifty's asking why
he wasn't coming to his besties defense
I'm talking hundreds and hundreds of
comments about the issue at hand Taylor
being really upset about scooter who
manages artists she's had issues with in
the past
buying her old record label and gaining
control of all her master recordings but
now Edie is responding to this fan
saying quote I have been speaking
directly to her like I always do a lot
of fans did not love that response
especially when you take into
consideration that Edie just
collaborated with Justin Bieber who
spoke out against Taylor in this whole
fiasco
and that they are actually longtime pals
to one of these vocals their history
he's one of the best vocalists
something funny to note in that same
interview back in 2017 and also talked
to et of the how Taylor recently it will
definitely happen again and while EDD is
supporting Taylor in his own way Brendon
Urie who she collabed with on me is
speaking up and very loudly how did I
stand with Taylor of course I mean it's
just like a the show to learn how awful
people can be you know what I mean
just for a profit PR o fi t just for a
monetary gain I should also note that
Taylor's other BFF Camilla Kibeho has
also weighed in on Twitter saying that
she really does believe all artists
should own their life's work as we wait
for this whole thing to get resolved a
source tells ET that scooter has reached
out to mutual friends on Monday to
explain the deal to Taylor quote scooter
wanted to clear the air privately but he
has not heard back from Taylor to talk
it out ET has reached out to Taylor's
reps for comments all right guys what do
you make of how Ed is handling the
situation let me know and for all the
latest on Taylor scooter Edie Brendon
Justin and more keep it locked to all
things
ét until next time I'm Katie Krauss and
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]